Thomas Verrette, Director, Producer,
Editor: That is a curious question...
Film Courage: How does
creativity begin in darkness?
Thomas: I don't know. I could be dreaming
or driving. I could be in the middle of a
phone call and something will just pop into my
head. That to me is where my my thoughts go when
you talk about creativity coming out of darkness
because usually that kind of stuff is spontaneous
and really not related to what's happening
around me. Sometimes I feel like it's like
a daydream effect of Oh, that's interesting.
Maybe I should do something about that or write
something about it or whatever. I can't really
describe where that comes from or why it happens.
Writer's block is a thing I guess where it's
like no new ideas maybe it's just because you're
being paid to come up with ideas. That it can get
difficult whereas for me I'm constantly writing
but I've never been paid to be a writer at least
yet so I feel like the demand of creatively for
you to be constantly on if that's your profession
as a writer is way more difficult probably and
stressful to be constantly on an editor or a
director is like you you know yeah you might
have an off day but you're still making things
happen in a tangible way in front of you like
where the footage is exists in the computer that
you have to find your way through but as a writer
I think you know that could be really challenging
but for me those things tend to happen in the
middle of while I'm doing something else like I'm
i'm in the middle of editing a scene and then i've
thought about something completely random that I
want to make a point to to write down because I
don't know where that's going to be value it might
be valuable in the project but or the next project
or you know because all those ideas
I think influence the work that I'm
either about to do or currently doing as well so
to to figure out where it all comes from though
I don't know I mean can you be taught
to be creative yes but there's also a
I think something like born like you're
born with this or people are born with a
exceptional you know I don't I don't
think I'm like the Stephen Hawking of of
like you know in in a sense of of or like this
Steven Spielberg you know I'm just trying to make
my way to try to create stories and tell them
but I think that there's some natural talent
that I was just gifted with that and again was
cultivated at a young age for me and that really
I think has helped contribute to where I
am now and hopefully where I continue to go
but but where it came from I mean is anybody's
guess I think that when you see somebody's
working like inspired like it changes
you like for me like you know that's
that's just why I think that's why we have those
reactions because it's like where did that even
come from how did they even create that or
think of that or do it that way or you know
even making all those collaborations happen every
single person and in in like I mean I hate to use
lord of the rings but it's like when I saw that
film I'm like yeah the set design the music the
directing the actors everybody just this magic
moment happened and I mean that means that that
creativity existed and all of them individually
first before it came to that moment too so
I just think it's all fascinating I have
no idea how it happens sometimes it's just
the universe to me is that the film that impacted
you the most lord of the rings I would say it's
definitely up there for sure yeah not Gattaca
not Gattaca in the same sense no I think Laura
Lorraine is the one that that really Gattaca is
a movie that that that intellectually stimulates
me in in in other ways maybe just because of when
I first saw it but lord of the rings is something
I'd never seen before and and so that was I think
why it showed me the magic of filmmaking in a in
in like the biggest and boldest way possible
what is day one of your writing process like
usually I am jotting down random ideas on just
a document and eventually like sort of like
highlights of a structure to some extent like
whatever I can come up with but then I don't know
I mean it changes depending on what I'm what I'm
working on and I think again every script is like
slightly different too collaborating and writing
with a writing partner is like my preferred way of
working as a writer just because again I think
that having somebody to bounce ideas off of
critique tell you that that idea is not good but
this one but that made me think of this one which
maybe is better and then you're like no that's not
good but now we're getting somewhere you know what
I mean like that part of that process is is really
fun for me I know a lot of people prefer to write
alone and yeah I don't know it's got to be like
an organic process at least for me right now I'm
still kind of early on in my my writing career
I guess because i've only really written this
projects that i've made which which is
sort of at a necessity to some extent
but I don't think i'll always do it that way
I might be the guy that gives you an idea as a
writer I might write it myself or collaborate or
you know co-write it I'm not really that needy I
guess in that part of the process I just the the
script is a blueprint for the movie so I think
as a director i'll always be involved but or I'd
like to think I will always be involved but maybe
i'll find the right script immediately and then
just like let's go you know I don't know it's a
long way ended up a long way around saying I don't
I mean it just starts with jotting down ideas but
that's as a writer it's like that but even as a
you know director of shot shooting like plans and
all that stuff it all starts it's got to start on
paper for me writing things down is how I remember
for me you know like note taking and all
that stuff it all it all comes back around
for me like it will stay in my brain if I
write it that's basically what I'm saying
so I might not think about it for four years
but it's still probably in there somewhere
I hope what is day seven of your writing process
like well hopefully i've gotten somewhere
by that point but I still think that like
the half the battle is figuring out kind of
what this I mean you know your structure but you
know what the story is that you're trying to tell
it's you know I hope maybe the ending I don't know
I mean like writing a script it can take me like
you know three years to get to the end
it can take me six months it just depends
for I am the bluebird how long did it take you
to finish the script oh well I'm the bluebird
I was in film school at the time so I think
it took as long as I had in the class to get
into production I think it was like three months
and that movie was you know not ready to be shot
like for sure but that's something that i've
experienced in particular in the editing and
again where I think why I think editing has been
the path that i've followed since then out of
necessity but also just because that part of the
process is where the movie got crafted and also
we released that film as implanted in 2012.
so I am the bluebird was the original title
and was also I think 20 minutes longer
at that point too and so all of that was
I guess the long-winded version of saying yeah
I shot it I think I spent maybe four months on
the script but that was I would I think it was
never ready to really be shot and I learned that
the hard way and so I would maybe just say that I
can oh at least i'll say i'll never do that again
if I if I can help it I don't want to
go into a production on something that
where the script isn't ready unless of course
it's a documentary where you don't have one
which I just did and that was also very different
and interesting too but but you have a three-act
structure with a documentary in some ways
yes you do you definitely have a structure
and but again you're create you're writing it
as an editor though in that case which you know
you're you have oh I mean you can you know we have
a lot of archive in Zero Gravity and there's other
ways to kind of enhance that storyline but but in
general it was the story unfolding in front of you
is what the movie is and you only
have so much control over that
whereas and if it's a script you can obviously
rewrite a scene and do a hundred different ways
to to get there so like with implanted it was
not ready to be shot with Zero Gravity it was
there's no like we had to start shooting it
to make the movie you know so it's very two
sides of the same coin but the end result was
you know is the story going to be compelling
and you know of course you're not going
to go on that journey unless you think it
think it is but you learn a lot along the
way for no matter what the project is.
Where does your creativity begin?